mundo ruso 15 antes de la escuela blackies
como te gusta este mundo ruso
[música]
mariupol burlyaev será hoy
otro receptor de aviación de cosecha
artillería
proyecto de sistema volley recuerda
el valor de mariupol se convirtió en su no un siglo
Defiendo si el guerrero se convirtió en el marido de los que quitan
en el barón, cierro toda Ucrania, intente
por mi experiencia encontraran mis campos del año
Ucrania
[música]
recibimos confirmación esta mañana
de la Federación Rusa del Ministerio
defensa de la federación rusa que pasa
de mariupol a la ciudad de zaporozhye vora
dnieper está a salvo con carteles como este
con el apoyo de la Cruz Roja, debemos
se dirigían hacia la ciudad
Zaporizhia, desafortunadamente
el momento en que ya estábamos listos empezó
bombardeo del ejército regular de la Federación Rusa
federación a lo largo del corredor a lo largo del cual
tuvimos que mudarnos
Puedo campo y estoy en casa
siguiente siguiente ella está ahí pierdes así que para
tenia barbas con 14 brazo y y
esposas de brujas tu no eres el se lo llevaron
aún más de sus hijos, nuestros ríos, sabíamos
Y
[música]
aquí está el patio
hospital de Maternidad
[música]
los niños eran la suma de cualquier
andra
[música]
bombardeo
casa nueva
[música]